this morning we're looking at the role
of social media in contributing to our
country's political divide
sites like twitter and facebook have
begun flagging posts by president trump
and others
that include misinformation on elections
in covet 19.
the move has frustrated many of the
president's supporters
who've responded by turning to platforms
like parlor which calls itself
a premium free speech app errol barnett
shows us why the emergence of these
unregulated forms
could make it harder for us to find
common ground
i'm proud to join parlor
this platform gets what free speech is
all about
paula which is described as a twitter
for conservatives has seen a rapid rise
in popularity
since the election topping apple's
download charts last week
with more than 10 million users can we
now
move everybody from twitter to parlor
it's become a platform of choice for
millions of conservatives
like re-elected colorado congressman ken
buck
to voice frustrations and share ideas
ideas
bucks says companies like twitter and
facebook are censoring
the best antidotes to misinformation is
more good information
it's not censoring or regulating or
filtering
bad information that we have to be
educated as a public
congressman you have seen though that i
guess the expression has been proven
true that a lie
travels much faster than the truth an
erroneous
headline will be shared online and seen
and engaged with
by more people than the correction so do
you really trust most americans
to fact check everything they engage
with
i absolutely trust americans and i think
that's one of the differences between
the left and the right and that's one of
the reasons why
an organization or a company like parlor
can get started
but as the number of users grow so does
the misinformation
being spread unproven accounts of voter
fraud and covert 19
hoax claims run rampant on sites like
parlor
with almost no filter parlor i think
it's dangerous because it's actually
encouraging people to get
into yet another hyper-confirming
like-minded reality
in which people will be even more
overwhelmingly convinced that their
spite is right
tristan harris is a computer scientist
and says in some ways social media
platforms
create tailor-made realities
post-election protests have highlighted
this growing polarization
we're not conceding because we've won
the election we just want it to be
revealed
and if it takes it to the courts we're
ready to go the distance liberals and
conservatives battling over not just
opinions
but basic facts we know that social
media has been dealing
out conspiracies to us because it's
never been easier to assert
um salacious realities that have no
basis in fact
than it is with social media so i really
really worry about
the the death of trust paula ceo john
mates told cnbc recently his app
was for everyone and that users control
the content they see
we don't curate content the people who
use the platform do
they choose what they trust what they
don't trust we can't have
an election stolen by by like this now
millions of loyal supporters of
president trump will soon be adjusting
to a new reality
joe biden entering the white house in
january
but if the incoming president-elect
wants to get anything
done harris says he'll have to break
through the echo chamber
if he really wants to take on whether
it's coveted 19 climate change or
economic recovery or
you know systemic racism you're not
going to be able to take on any of those
issues
if the information that we're all
consuming is in these different micro
realities that are incompatible with
each other
now despite being viewed by the
anti-defamation league as a haven for
hate speech
paula tells us in a statement its app is
quote a destination for everyone who
believes in the first amendment
and free speech we also asked them about
online claims that it
um bans liberal viewpoints and their
response was that they quote
unequivocally deny that there is a
banning because of viewpoints
paula does say it bans for criminal
posts violence
or spam but this is where we are now in
a place where you can effectively
choose your own micro reality eureka
all right errol thank you so much it
seems like you can get your information
a la carte all right don't you welcome
diversity of thought
i want i don't want to hear my own
thoughts parroted back to me
that's why that's you there are a lot of
people who don't mind
not having that sort of other point of
view but
it will be interesting to see if you
know a more liberal or progressive
however you want to describe it moves on
to that platform
to offer that that opportunity i might
just get rid of social media all
together how about that i don't think so
you're up on
i know what happens are you why are you
calling me out eureka
you are you really are thank you i am on
social
media when i met you you had like 12 15
000 on twitter i was like trying to be
you i am on social media a lot i got to
get off of that my time my screen time
keeps going up every week
take a break yeah take a breath breathe
just breathe